here's the kind of question that you've
been looking at quite a bit okay this is
back from the greatest coefficient
exercise right so the question gives you
this and what it asks for is what is the
greatest absolute value of the
coefficient you can find okay
in other words hey welcome back
in other words don't worry about the
sign don't worry about the fact that
that negative is gonna make it alternate
back and forth and back and forth just
tell me the biggest number okay
irrespective of negatives so when I see
that when I see that the question
doesn't care about sign the first thing
I do is I say well therefore I'm going
to change the question so sign is no
longer an issue okay the difference
between 1 - 7 X to the power of 9 + 1 +
7 X to the power of 9 all the numbers
are the same but this guy will start
with a 1 and then it'll go - something
plus something minus something and all
the numbers are otherwise identical okay
so therefore I'm going to say consider
this other guy solve the question for
that the rest of that marches through
just 5 you consider your K term you
count your K coefficient I should say
your K + 1 coefficient you do your
comparison and then you get to the end
and off you go you get a number okay so
no big dramas however do want to point
out that they don't always ask you they
don't always say I don't care about the
sign sometimes they do care about the
time we looked at this yesterday okay so
here I think is probably the best way to
go if they're no longer saying consider
absolute value I still more or less
solve the question the same way with one
little difference I add something on
okay I say just like in my equations
reducible to a quadratic I'm like oh
well I've solved a problem
comingcoming I've solved a problem
that's related to yours but it's not
your problem
so I need to go back to the way you
phrased it see what differences there
are that account for them so we said the
difference was um was that negative sign
right and it's gonna make some of the
terms negative so what I do is I come
over to here and you can see I've
written down all my terms have you
noticed this is a really useful this
inequality thing even though it takes a
long time to write them all out super
helpful I can know
if every alternate one is negative which
ones will they be okay now the first
term think about it the first term is
just going to be I'll come back to the
original thing it's just gonna be 9c 0
times 1 to the power of 9
yeah I'll write that down actually uh
sorry 90 0 times 1 to the power of 9 yes
and for completeness sake I can say I
have 0 lots of those are you comfortable
with that now tell me is that positive
or negative it's positive ok good
that means when I have a look here this
one that's C naught that's okay but the
next one is negative and then
alternating after that and alternating
are to that and alternating out to that
all those guys will have negative signs
attached to them
ok so I have to take them out of the
running clearly a negative 1 is not
gonna be the greatest coefficient if
sign matters to me now then I look back
and I say okay well does that affect the
answer that I've got has it invalidated
the answer that I wanted the answer is
in this case no I'm fine eight eight is
still one of the positive ones so thumbs
up my answer is preserved however if it
was actually invalidated if I find oh oh
the answer is C 7 and C 7 is negative
okay the answer the next step is simple
you just say well it must be one on
either side right and just like I
evaluated to see eight and got a number
evaluates C 6 and C sorry
yeah well I'm imagining for C seven just
evaluate the ones on either side one of
them must be the biggest because that's
the way the coefficients work does that
make sense okay question
sure okay so what I would do like that I
would say I would still write this
because these seas they all apply to
this guy which I've just kind of
manufactured right so it's still okay
and then I would say at this point here
I'll take but four and then I'm going to
go back to the original question right
I'm gonna say no I'm gonna say but for
that power of nine why don't we say are
all the odd ones are the ones I'm gonna
take out right I'm gonna say see sorry
yes even well I'm looking at odd numbers
like ones threes fives etc rather than
first second third anyway you get one
which ones I mean I'll say c1 c3 c5 etc
they're all negative right so I'm like
therefore I'm going to test I'm
literally going to say test c6 test CA
or whatever it happens to be okay
so I'm gonna leave you in a car I'm not
gonna muck around with like oh man which
way did the guys summon a that's just
confusing don't need to wear